das ist ein justiz-skandal der Mordfall
Zoe die 17-jährige die ist vergewaltigt
und grausam ermordet worden vor zwei
Jahren von dem damals Gleichaltrigen
Lukas mit dem hatte sie sich zum Date
verabredet doch dieser Typ er kommt
jetzt einfach davon da kommt jetzt
einfach da vorne ist auf freiem Fuß ja
und das nicht weil er etwa unschuldig
wäre sondern weil Justiz geschlammt hat
das Verfahren hat zu lange gedauert 22
Monate saß ein U-Haft und da ist nur an
57 Tagen verhandelt wurden und das sei
eine unzulässige prozessverzögerung
Ergebnis ja er kommt frei und der Mord
an so wie der bleibt vorerst unbestraft
Thorsten schleif ist bei uns hier bei
Bild live Vorsitzender Richter am
Schöffengericht in Dinslaken und
Buchautor über ja Justiz und
justizskandale größte herzlicher schleif
wenn Sie diesen Fall hören diesen Fall
Zoe der so endet was geht ihn durch den
Kopf
ja ist leider bezeichnet für eine
Vielzahl von Strafprozessen wie wir sie
in der letzten Zeit immer wieder in
Deutschland erleben dass sie nämlich
sehr sehr lange dauern und das dann die
Untersuchungshaft in ihre Grenzen kommt
das ganze ist aufgrund eben einer
Verzögerung können Sie einmal ganz kurz
erklären wie es dazu kommen kann bzw was
überhaupt der rechtliche Rahmen dafür
ist
ja vorliegend sind zwei elementare
Grundsätze unseres rechtsstaatsgefragt
nämlich einmal die Unschuldsvermutung
des Angeklagten und der im Strafprozess
geltende Beschleunigungsgrundsatz das
heißt ein Angeklagter soll sich
möglichst schnell darauf einstellen
können was kommt eigentlich auf mich zu
womit habe ich zu rechnen wenn der
Prozess zu Ende ist wenn man hier
bedenkt 22 Monate verhandelt 57
hauptverhandlungstagen nur 120 von denen
weniger als zwei Stunden das ist einfach
zu lange für so einen Prozess was würden
sie in so einem Fall den Eltern sagen
den Eltern von Zoe
ja den Eltern von Zoe das ist das
Problem dass nämlich die Angehörigen
gerade so etwas nicht nachvollziehen
können mit rechtlich nachvollziehen
können unser Rechtsstaat muss einfach in
solchen Fällen schneller agieren wenn
zum Beispiel der Verteidiger keine Zeit
hat gibt es die Möglichkeit einen
weiteren Pflichtverteidiger ergänzen zur
verfahrensicherung zu bestellen damit
eben solche Fehler nicht auftreten das
ist vorliegen offensichtlich alles
versäumt worden Lukas der Täter er wurde
verurteilt so 10 Jahren Haft jetzt eben
frei wegen ja wegen dieser verschlampung
sozusagen kommt der trotzdem noch in den
Knast
ja wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
Urteil ist ja nur ein vorläufiges Urteil
es ist noch nicht rechtskräftig das
heißt aufgrund dieses Urteils darf
niemand eingesperrt werden die
Freiheitsstrafe darf noch nicht
vollstreckt werden die Untersuchungshaft
die ist jetzt ausgelaufen wenn das
Urteil allerdings rechtskräftig wird
muss er natürlich seine Freiheitsstrafe
antreten instas danke an Thorsten
schleif der sich mit justizskandalen
auseinandersetzt zu diesem ja so
unbefriedigen Fall Zoe dem neuen
justizkandal danke
[Musik]